[Music]
hello there august is here again and
with it maxed the start of the games
industry going into overdrive like usual
let's go through a bunch of games that
are coming out this month and as always
i found a shed load of free to play
games that could be your new favorite
pastime so let's do this
the biggest game of the month is the
long-awaited return of saint rowe in the
past there was two types of saints row
game the semi-serious gta inspired
originals and the completely ridiculous
superhero sandbox that we explored in
saints row 4. after playing a few hours
it's clear to see that 2022 saints row
is more like the original games less
bombastic but just as over the top as
always we play as the boss and take to
the street to build a criminal empire
big enough to take down all our
competitors saints row is littered with
constant humor and although some jokes
are a bit cringy it's the same saints
row vibe as always i've played about
four hours so far and can confirm the
missions keep getting crazier and
crazier starting off from your first
decision to decide how big your package
is saints row definitely does not take
itself too seriously so if you need a
different take on the gta formula saints
row is reborn on august 23rd on
playstations 4 and 5 the xboxes and pc
spider-man 2 is confirmed to be arriving
next year 2023 and sony are finally
ready to let peter's first adventure
jump platforms spider-man remastered is
coming to the pc the story-driven game
from 2018 and all its dlc will be
available to pc players and there's a
bit of me that can't wait to see what
can be achieved visually on a high-end
pc 4k ray traced super sampling and
ultra widescreen enabled it's going to
be epic the story follows peter as he
faces doc ock electro rhino task master
scorpion mr negative and tons more the
dlc even brings us the super forward
black cat the slick swinging combo
spinning and loving face changing
spider-man remastered comes to pc on
august 12th and for the people who
played it years ago this means new
spider-man 2 info will be coming soon
this game may be seen as a little niche
destroy all humans 2 re-probed yet
another third person action game this
month but unlike the others we can body
snatch in this one destroy all humans 2
was first released in 2006 and reprobed
is the remake dragging the visuals and
the control schemes 15 plus years
forward as the name suggests destroy all
humans sees an alien race come to earth
and take over by any means necessary set
10 years after the first game in 1969 in
which the us has fallen we play as
crypto disguised as the president of the
usa who blames russia for all the
attacks genius the gameplay is all about
destruction whether that's in the air on
foot or using military vehicles with
some crazy weapons to harness too oh and
it also supports co-op play allowing you
to take over the world with a friend by
your side destroy all humans 2 reprobed
is a reduced price game retailing at
40.40 euros which is 35 pounds here in
the uk august the 30th on ps5 xbox
series and pc
[Music]
okey dokey free game fam let's do this
check out the biggest game of the month
that doesn't cost you anything rumble
verse originally scheduled to release in
february rumbleverse was taken away for
extra polish to be applied and now it's
ready for its full release i put
together a preview last month but i'll
try describe the game briefly battle
royale and wwe combine into one game we
first fire ourselves onto the island
with basic moves mastered we then pick
up other moves in game by reading books
left by legendary wrestlers i'm sure
i've seen a rock bottom or two and a
spinning pile driver as well rumble
verse has super simple controls the
strategy is basically rock paper
scissors replaced with strike block and
grapple strikes can be blocked but
grapples cannot be blocked and if one
player presses grapple and the other
player presses strike the strike will
always win easy to pick up almost
impossible to master rumbleverse is
crammed with unlockable cosmetics and as
it's a free-to-play game expect paid
cosmetics to target your wallet
rumbleverse releases on august 11th on
playstation xbox and pc
more free games you say okay how about
century age of ashes a multiplayer
dragon battle game we are promised
intense three versus three and six on
six fast-paced aerial battles unleashing
hell from above the other game modes
include gates of fire kinda like a
capture the flag on dragons spoils of
war a mode which asks teams to steal
each other's gold and protects their own
and survival where eight players go at
it in a free-for-all century age of
ashes gives us four classes of dragon
rider to choose from each with their own
unique abilities from the stealthy
phantom hiding traps away to the
stormrazer harnessing the power of
thunder and lightning just like
rumbleverse this game tries to get your
money through unlocks and cosmetics and
there's a bump in the road both the
playstation and xbox versions of age of
ashes were due to be released in july
yet only pc and xbox can play the game
right now that's because the playstation
version was delayed which usually means
it didn't pass certification the age of
ashes team were quick to promise that
the game would still release on
playstation over the summer and august
is the last full month for that to
happen so keep an eye out for it if
you're on playstation or play it right
now if you're on pc and xbox
another free game is from capcom and
it's something for people who like retro
games if you hate old games yeah you
best skip over this one recently the
second capcom arcade stadium released
with a bunch of new well not new
extremely old retro games to buy they're
only a few dollars each the thing is at
completely random times capcom will make
games free to keep forever if you
download them in time if you've been
watching these videos over the last year
you already have street fighter 2 ghosts
and ghouls 1942 commando and final fight
all for free right now capcom arcade
stadium 2 has a free game built in if
you should download it it's a 1984 game
sun sun a side-scrolling platformer that
couldn't look more 80s if it tried it's
not a wow game but i'll keep letting you
know when other retro classics go free a
quick note about another free game we
looked at last month multiverses a take
on super smash bros i got a crazy amount
of abuse in the comments and in my
twitter dms because people say the game
isn't free to play so this is a quick
public service announcement to put
things to rest multiverses has its free
to play soft launch on july 26th that's
tomorrow if you're watching when i
release this video the reason the game
is priced in the store is for special
editions early editions so if you don't
want to pay for the game just hold on
tight it's coming for free very soon
it's common practice to have paid early
access especially for games which are
competitive
[Music]
okay let's transition away from free to
play have you seen roller drum roller
drum is a third person action shooter
that combines high octane gun foo with
movement you'd see in something like a
tony hawk game we skate around the
location building up a combo of tricks
while simultaneously fighting foes
without making a single false move
moving in and out of slow motion the
cel-shaded art style seems to be
something which either attracts players
or scares them away what do you reckon
those on ps plus with premium can play
the game for a day for free as part of a
trial program as i'm writing this the
price hasn't been confirmed by
playstation yet but on the steam page
roller drum is priced at twenty dollars
for the first two weeks and then it goes
back up to thirty dollars afterwards
[Music]
back in 2018 the two-point hospital stim
game released allowing us to build and
run our own hospital and cure patients
of some weird and wonderful made-up
illnesses well there's another two-point
game arriving two-point campus we are
the dean of an educational establishment
and are tasked with getting the
younglings through to their graduation
two-point campus has you hiring and
firing the staff deciding what courses
are available and trying to desperately
boost morale of the students who regret
their life choices campus is a
reduced-priced game retailing at 40
euros 40 which is 30 quid here in the uk
so if you want to be the headmaster look
out for it on august 9th on playstation
xbox switch and pc let's give a quick
nod to some other games releasing in
august thimeisia a soulsborne inspired
rpg releasing on august 9th on ps5 xbox
series and pc is it time asia or fine
media anyway if you like souls born
games this one looks good if you want to
hunt digital prey in a realistic way you
should look out for the way of the
hunter on august 16th which really
doubles down on realism driving to your
praise location tracking them from afar
and then finally taking them out to get
your dinner and finally if you need a
fix of ninja turtles the tmnt the
cowabunga collection releases on august
30th it includes a smoggers board of
classics from the snares gameboy genesis
and arcade eras retro gamers of the
world unite so there's a whole bunch of
games dropping in august what are you
playing i'm hoping to see many of you
trying multiverses and rumble verse i'm
adam you're awesome it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time